je veux saluer nos candidats je voudrais
leur dire vraiment individuellement à
chacun d'entre eux qui l'ont été et
qu'ils sont remarquables dans cette dans
cette campagne merci de votre soutien
merci de votre engagement merci de votre
mobilisation
notre conseil national est une rencontre
interactive libre ce sera le cas
aujourd'hui puisque nos candidats
disposeront d'un long temps des changes
avec lui nous sommes aujourd'hui 150
mille adhérents
cela nous installe oui
ça mérite vos applaudissements
cela nous installe comme la première
formation politique du pays et comme la
seule force d'alternance crédible face à
emmanuel macron le temps est venu de
réparer notre pays jeudi réparer parce
que les dégâts sont considérables vous
ne voulez plus nous ne voulons plus à
l'élysée de celui qui a reculé dès le
début de son mandat face aux à dist de
notre dame des landes le 4e soir nous
allons nous retrouver nous devrons nous
retrouver une seule équipe un seul
projet un projet pour la france le
projet de la droite républicaine
si nous nous disparaissions mes amis qui
incarnera l'indépendance et la grandeur
de la france personne qui parlera
d'autorité travail personne qui aura
toujours envie de rassembler les
français comme nos pères fondateurs nous
l'enseigné personnes c'est la raison
pour laquelle cette élection
présidentielle c'est aussi l'enjeu de
l'avenir de notre famille politique et
de notre pays
la france a besoin de nous nous nous en
gardons lors la liberté et la justice
nous sommes les héritiers d'une histoire
qui ne vibre pas aux paroles capitularde
de pet en mai aux souvenirs des marins
rebelles de l'île de sant de gaulle
malraux pompidou chirac sarkozy et tant
d'autres encore comme vous je ne les
oublie pas je ne renie rien et je
prolonge le combat moi je ne veux pas me
réveiller demain et apprendre que les
centrales nucléaires et apprendre que le
mont saint michel et apprendre que nos
tgv ont été vendus à des chinois à des
américains par le fmi par la banque
centrale européenne ou que sais-je il ya
une chose que vous devez avoir en tête
c'est qu'au fond le plus important dans
cette campagne présidentielle c'est la
chose suivante voulez vous que nous
existions toujours pas ce que je vous
propose c'est que nous soyons capables
ensemble de d'imposer à ceux qui veulent
nous imposer d'extérieur notre propre
modèle de prospérité une france qui
doute qui hésitent qui se cherche une
france qui a peur dans la nuit qui
semble nous condamner
inexorablement au déclin notre
responsabilité est immense nous sommes
les seuls à pouvoir allumer la lumière
de l'espérance française nous sommes les
seuls à pouvoir interrompre le
déclassement d'une nation qui a façonné
l'histoire et éclairer le monde oui mes
amis notre famille aujourd'hui à
rendez-vous avec son histoire